the radical left rampaging across the
country over roe versus wade while
democrats attacked the supreme court's
legitimacy the fbi is investigating
after pro-abortion extremists torched a
pro-life colorado pregnancy center
leaving behind graffiti that says if
abortions aren't safe neither are you
in los angeles a man is facing possible
attempted murder charges after attacking
a cop with a makeshift flame thrower
during a protest over there
and total chaos in phoenix where arizona
lawmakers
say they were held hostage by an angry
crowd outside the state capitol police
eventually had to use tear gas to clear
him out
democrats in congress echoing the fury
by pushing for drastic measures against
the supreme court
do you think lying at a confirmation
hearing is an impeachable offense i
believe so
i believe so i believe lying under oath
is an impeachable offense this court has
lost legitimacy i believe we need to get
some confidence back in our court and
that means
we need more justices on the united
states supreme court and while democrats
push the white house to act the best
they're gonna get is the kamala photo op
the vice president's getting brutally
mocked by liberals for this photo she
posted of herself just watching the
ruling
all right danny you've had the weekend
to kind of take it all in
what do you think here on a monday well
it's interesting i just want to add one
other thing to the um
the violence over the weekend so in
vermont there was actually a tax on the
state capitol um
vandalism graffiti the thing is that
vermont in just 2019 passed a law so
that in the state of vermont there is a
codified right in the state constitution
for a woman to have the right to choose
and the right to have an abortion so i
don't know what they're why are they
attacking the state capital
in vermont um that doesn't make any
sense but that also i think over the
weekend not only did we think about it
but
it's hard to tell exactly how this is
going to play out in the long run
emotions running super high um
especially on the left i am a little
surprised that the pro-choice forces
seem a little
uh unclear as to what they're going to
do next they had ample warning the draft
opinion had been out there for about 55
days there are state
court the state legislatures that are
going to be taking up this issue there
are lawsuits already happening but also
as people start to realize that oh in
your in
as these decisions go back to the states
if you are in xyz state nothing changes
for you now
is it possible that
liberal women in new york are going to
be really upset about
the women losing right to choose in a
state like mississippi is possible will
that motivate them to vote yes but they
vote in new york right so i i don't know
practically how that's going to turn out
i do think that this will help the
democrats
at least a little bit with suburban
women fundraising and certainly
fundraising this does not help
republicans in the fundraising front as
i did a little research in that today
that
you know inflation is starting to take a
bite out of the small dollar fundraising
on on both sides but really on the right
but this issue for democrats they'll
raise a ton of money from celebrities
but if you think back in march of 2021
the democrats i'm sorry that texas
passed their abortion law and remember
there was all the conundrum there was a
huge fuss
but
national polling on abortion didn't
change at all so i i'm open-minded and
looking at it and i'll just say one last
thing
one of the reasons ruth bader ginsburg
was very frustrated with the roe v wade
decision is that up until then in 1972
the state legislatures were moving
forward to try to do what vermont just
did
vermont in 2019 said okay in the state
legislature in the state constitution
women right to abortion is there that
all stopped all that activity in the
states really stopped when they came up
with the idea that there was this right
to privacy in the in the constitution
now that's over and the fight will
continue hopefully more peacefully than
what we saw over the weekend greg were
these mostly peaceful protests over the
weekend i was talking to dana about this
just moments ago maybe it's me after
three years of lawlessness and just
seeing crap every day that i thought
this was much less than a night of rage
and that could just be on my own
subjective
opinion comparing and i could be
definitely wrong because i'm not there
but i guess the visual spectacle of this
was not what i think the media wished it
could be i think that that the reason
why they were so playing down the stuff
that was going on in front of the
supreme court justices homes is hoping
that intimidation and and the threat of
a mob of of an angry vengeful mob would
somehow change things and it didn't um i
think too it's interesting a lot of the
protests are in cities that aren't going
to be affected by it and so i think what
you're going to see is just a lot of
kind of like this there's a lot of
ignorance going around a lot of people
don't know what this means i love
hearing you know
famous liberals renouncing their
citizenship well where good luck finding
a country
that has abortion on demand like the
united states if you look at any map of
europe you're going to find out you're
going to find out that most countries in
western europe and elsewhere are like
pretty pretty much more strict then
there's this complaint about you know
republicans want you to be born but they
don't want to they don't
want to care we care about you when
you're born this is what what uh the
lady from the view said but the evidence
right now is in is totally in reverse
who's outspoken on crime right who's
outspoken on black and black crime who's
outspoken on the price of gas and the
price of baby uh uh baby formula the
economy
who's talking about school choice who's
worried about kids being trapped in in
in terrible schools the lockdown economy
it was it wasn't democrats or teachers
unions it was the republicans so if you
want to talk about responsibility of
people who are born republicans have
been there all along it's just you
didn't you didn't like the grim truth of
what you were protecting
when you heard some of the politicians
out there on the shows talking about
packing the cord and impeaching the
justices
do you think that's going anywhere no
well first of all
there is this
this this miscalculation people don't
understand that what happened with the
dobbs decision was that the court said
that there is no constitutional right to
an abortion they never said abortions
are illegal
they never said that they are
unconstitutional they just said you
don't have a constitutional right to
them so all you folks that talk about
you know what you know that all of this
stuff is a tearing down democracy and
we've got to protect democracy why don't
you learn a little about democracy get
together and now fight for it in the
state legislatures where you will make a
difference as to whether or not
abortions will be legal or not that is
the essence of democracy the idea of
saying that these justices as aoc said
you know uh lied i mean i think that one
of the complaints had to do with a
personal
discussion and one of the senator's
office
first of all this is the same thing that
all liberal justices have said under
article 3 of the constitution they are
to decide cases and controversies you
are not when you appear before a senate
committee deciding a case or a
controversy you're going to say i will
decide this case based upon the facts
and the law as presented to me i will
not prejudge any situation because then
you're going to vote for me and i had to
say i did the same thing as a judge
people would say to me well how do you
feel about this crime or that crime or
that well no i i will do my job as best
i can to substantiate that those crimes
and those laws that have to be protected
as a judge now none of these justices
said that precedent could not be
overturned none of them said that there
was no lie
and the essence of where we are now is
that they're just bad uh
they don't like the results so they want
to change the rules of the game and so
they want to pack the court which is
ridiculous because then the court is
nothing other than a legislative branch
that reflects the rule of the mob the
left doesn't know how absurd they look
they're fighting they're having these
hissy fits every time they don't like
something they hit the streets they
become violent at the summer of 2020.
it's just they're losing credibility as
opposed to complaining about the supreme
court uh losing legitimacy
take it home harold ford jr so the
violence i never understand why people
engage in violence too and it goes on
both sides there are people who blew up
abortion clinics or
places over the years that where
abortions were performed and now you
have people out doing this i don't know
how you're going to make a difference
engaging in violence i think peaceful
protesting is fine but the violence is
inexcusable and they should be
prosecuted when it comes to the polling
one of the things that really disturbs
me in all of this is 20
right after this decision
scotus's approval rating dropped to 25
percent now in the legislative and
executive branch you expect those
numbers to fluctuate that's a low number
even for even for president biden that's
a low number for congress that's a low
number but at least you have elections
every two years for the congress four
years for the president obviously six
years for the senate judge you talked
about being a judge and some of the
things that you talked about so many of
our judges in this country are elected
so when they say they're going to do
certain things and they don't do them
voters are able to go and unelect them
i'm with you i don't think we should
pack the court but i got to tell you uh
and the majority of the country agrees
with you as well it'll be interesting to
see
where that goes in addition i think that
the larger question for me is and justin
i think i've heard you say something on
the show about it i think when you look
at 15 to 20 weeks for
a woman to be able to get an abortion i
think there's a wide acceptance of that
i think when president clinton said rare
legal and safe uh unfortunately that
that middle of the of the road position
on on this issue is largely
unrepresented in politics you have those
who don't want it at all and you have
those who want it on demand i think the
question that we will get back to uh
from an electoral standpoint will be
will be that now what alarms democrats i
think in alarms me more so than the
decision was was was alarming but as you
give this all back to the states is what
justice thomas said in his concurring
opinion about privacy and the
expectation of in fact the constitution
does not specifically enumerate
protections on certain things
contraceptions being one of them or even
your digital identity i think if
democrats are smart for the long term
you begin to you launch an effort to try
uh to say look maybe there's an
amendment to the constitution that we
need to have that enumerates privacy and
we enumerate privacy from the standpoint
uh for families for women and let that
debate happen and i'm willing to oh let
that debate and i have thoughts on i'm
sure we all do but democrats need to do
what the federalist society did 50 years
ago when they wanted to overturn roe
when it was a central part of what some
of these groups wanted to do lay out a
plan for the long term and in the short
term
the violence doesn't work lay out what
the concerns should be not just for
women but for men because there were men
who supported the federalist society
much like there were there are women who
support this decision i hope we don't
engage in any more violence
and i remind everybody justice roberts
made this a 5-4 decision to overturn roe
oh yeah 6-3 decision on the mississippi
law which is where i wish the court
had stayed great conversation i'm very
impressed with each and every one of you
thank you
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now